the people I admire the most are not the
people we know I take a lot of 6 a.m
flights and I'm always really really
inspired only by when it's 4 15 in the
morning that I'm in the car and I'm
driving to LaGuardia or JFK and I'm
looking out the window in New York City
in Queens and just kind of the grind and
I'm seeing a 59 year old woman get out
of the Subway at 4 15 and go into work
and I don't know what it is about that
but that stuff way more to me it's the
people that nobody knows and I'll look
at that I'm like man maybe her husband
passed
America has four children still not
graduating
just to have a regular nine to five but
now she's had to do a six to nine in the
morning like I'm just so much more
inspired by that person I'd much more be
interested in mentored by someone that
got to 99 and smiled every day of their
life and they just might have worked on
a farm in Kansas those are the people
that inspire me